public defenders and former public  defenders gathered earlier today just  outside the original Justice Center to  support the black lives matter movement  now in a press release the organizers  say this is in solidarity of the  nationwide protests calling for justice  for those who have died from police  brutality the goal is to let the black  community know that we stand with you  and your lives matter as a community of  defenders that historically has stood by  the marginalized communities that has  stood by the poor the voiceless and the  often demonized we are here to say that  we love you and we stand with you during  the demonstration there was a moment of  silence for eight minutes and 46 seconds  in honor of the last moments of George  Floyd's life